Olá sejam bem-vindos para mais uma live
é um prazer estar aqui com vocês hoje eu
tô com problema de tempo eu tenho que
fazer uma reunião online por volta das
7:30 da noite então eu vou direto pras
perguntas tá mas tem muita pergunta hoje
tá então vou ter que ser mais objetivo
nas
respostas Boa noite Carlos kman Boa
noite Fernando castelani e boa noite en
então vamos às perguntas
primeira pergunta de Antônio
Renato D Alan lâmpada de luz Dev ser
verde né Tá faltando
de aqui deve ser isso é uma
alternativa saudável para luzes brancas
e amarelas ou então é vermelha né então
pode ser vermelha Qual é a mais benéfica
a luz vermelha fluorescente ou led luz
vermelha a Ava de 15 V perde o efeito
benéfico e começa a ter os efeitos
negativos da luz branca se uma pessoa
dormir com luz vermelha de 15 V acesa
não atrapalha o sono e nem causa insônia
sim sim a luz vermelha pode ser uma
alternativa para as luzes brancas e
amarelas ela tem uma série de benefícios
paraa saúde pode ajudar no sono e no
ritmo circadiano então a luz vermelha
ajuda a regular o ritmo circadiano
promove um sono mais profundo de melhor
qualidade isso ocorre Porque a luz
vermelha não suprime a produção de
melatonina pode ajudar na redução do
estresse na melhora da visão e pode ter
efeitos antiinflamatórios e ambas as
opções luz vermelha fluorescente LED
podem ser benéficas no entanto algumas
diferenças importantes a luz vermelha
fluorescente é mais suave e tem uma
frequência mais baixa que é mais
apropriado para ambientes de
sono a luz Vera de LED é mais intensa e
tem uma frequência mais alta O que torna
mais apropriado para uso em ambiente
trabalho ou
estudo então a luz de 15 V pode parte
dos seus efeitos benéficos e começa a
ter efeitos negativos semelhantes a luz
branca se ela for muito intensa ou se
ela tiver uma frequência muito alta
nesse caso pode suprimir a produção de
melatonina então dormir com uma luz
vermelha de 15 V acesa se ela estiver
suave e uma distância segura não vai
afetar o sono então deixe a luz não tão
próximo do seu rosto
agora a razão de ter que manter essa luz
acesa
e qual que seria Antônio Renato porque
eu entendo que o ideal é você dormir no
escuro
tá eu pedi na Live passada que você
indicasse uma ou duas macas de manteiga
Gu tá vou te passar aqui alguns nomes tá
Vou digitar aqui
na no chat tá bom PR gente passar pra
próxima pergunta que tem muita pergunta
hoje aqui
deixa eu ver se vai dar
para ficou meio esquisito aqui eu vou
ler aqui tá eh Gu beni ou beni tá tá
aqui no na mensagem mas ficou tudo meio
truncado deixa eu colocar
aqui pera aí não ficou boa essa essa
mensagem não deixa eu ver se consigo
apagar sim
is aqui é uma das
marcas
Pronto tem outra chi para
[Música]
mana Gu PR
mana e tem uma cham give for you tá bom
são três marcas aí que eu recomendo para
você vamos pra
próxima na sua opinião quais seriam os
melhores tratamentos suplementos para
osteofitose
ozonoterapia eu recomendo tá não
recomendo MMS porque eu não tenho dado
suficient para recomendar isso ou
CDs e aí seria o colágeno tipo do um bom
um bom suplemento o
C2 outro suplemento vitamina pra
desbloquear seu iPhone vitamina D3 e
omega3 também são bons suplementos
vitamina K2
o eh o silício orgânico também é um bom
suplemento o msm que é o enxofre
orgânico tá bom e a ozonioterapia também
muito interessante para para isso além
de fazer fisioterapia e exercícios
físicos
cúrcuma também curcumina e gar do diabo
também seria ótimas
opções Tiago qual sua opinião sobre
relação a rizotomia e os bloqueios
infiltrações para dores de pensamento na
lombar eu não sou cirurgião ortopédico
então eu não tenho as informações mais
completas possíveis sobre rizotomia Tá
mas ele é um procedimento minimamente
invasivo que é consiste né em realizar a
cauterização de nervos sensitivos
específicos com
radiofrequência para alivo da dor
lombar é indicada quando os tratamentos
conservadores com
antiinflamatórios não resolvem o
problema segundo consta tem baixo índice
de complicações ser as mais comuns dor
temporada no local da aplicação e
dormência na pele da
região os bloqueios e infiltrações
também são minimamente invasivas eu
optaria primeiro por esse procedimento
Antes de Partir pra rotom que é mais
invasivo só que se você coloca muitas
vezes a infiltração também pode ter
complicações tá isso também tem que ser
levado em consideração mas poucas vezes
usar corticoide o ácido hialurônico eu
entendo que é uma boa alternativa
Ok mas eu não sou especialista em em
risot tomia eu faria o bloqueio
filtração Antes de Partir paraa risot
tomia deixaria a rizotomia como segunda
opção
eh não entendi uma coisa pode ser que eu
não tenha
explicado que eu saiba os melhores
tratamentos de excelência para Disco São
Z terapia fisioterapia e
PRP sugiro que faça os três tratamentos
tá Eliseu além esses três tratamentos
você sugere mais algum tratamento Só uso
de antiinflamatório natural curcumina
garra do diabo
eh que
mais canela de
velho extrato de gengibre tá anates
naturais pode usar também óleo de
copaíba
e usar também cannabis tá bom são esses
tratamentos que eu recomendo então é
ozônio fisioterapia PRP e fitoterapia tá
bom
são esses quatro tratamentos que eu
indico você indicou umas cinco marcas de
sal lá no YouTube há muito tempo uma das
marcas de sal do Himalaia que você
indicou foi Smart posso comprar sal rosa
do Himalaia Smart percebi que atrás da
embalagem disse que pode conter soja
Suponha que esse aviso se deve
contaminação cruzada é isso se deve
porque pela legislação ele são obrigados
a colocar isso se existe qualquer chance
de ter contato com sja por isso que eles
colocam isso tá é muito mais uma
precaução legal do que de fato que o
produto Vai ter SOJA eles fazem isso
para evitar processo judicial Tá então
não deve considerar que tenha soja nesse
produto não nesse caso é uma boa ideia
trocar esse sal por outro não não vejo
necessidade disso não isso é uma
precaução eu conversei uma vez com Um
fabricante ele falou que não tinha nada
daquilo lá não Era exatamente o o sal
rosa mas era um fabricante de temperos
eles colocavam lá que poderia conter uma
série de coisas por causa dos
fornecedores que eles tinham e que
eventualmente o fornecedor poderia
mandar para eles alguma coisa com uma
contaminação cruzada e eles serem
responsabilizados então é uma coisa
muito mais legal do que real
tá ouvi dizer que só pode ingerir binol
depois que a pessoa parar de ingerir
remédio para pressão alta Não não é
verdade isso e o motivo disso é porque o
bikol disputa com mede o controle do
coração não não faz menor sentido essa
afirmação tá ô Eliseu não
confirmo eu vou ter que ser mais
objetivo aqui Pessoal vocês perceberam
que são 38
perguntas sobre que é possível ter
caganeira logo após fazer Z terapia
retal sim é possível a única estratégia
que eu imagino para evitar isso é fazer
jejun de 72 horas antes da sessão não
não tem nada a ver o Só se você quer
ficar 72 horas é muito tempo né
bastante tempo de jejum porém se eu
fizer auon terapia retal toda semana vai
ficar complicado fazer concordo por isso
que eu não recomendo você sugerem algum
suplemento que bloqueia a caganeira não
Não sugiro Não isso não é um problema
comum Eliseu tá não é um problema comum
você tá eh colocando uma importância
numa coisa que é muito
ocasional na Live passada você disse que
D3 em 130 deve ser microgramas né né
para quem não tem doença autoimune não é
bom ou é exame de sangue você tá falando
não sei deve ser exame de sangue não é
bom não eu falei que D3 acima de 100
para quem não tem doença tá foi isso que
escreveu aqui para quem não tem doença
não é bom não é bom porque você pode
correr risco de fazer hipercalcemia né
excesso de cálcio no sangue e vai correr
risco também à toa de acumular cálcio
nas articulações ou no coração ou nos
rins tá por isso não o custo benefício
não é bom não faz sentido ficar mantendo
Auto à toa sem ter uma doença autoimune
foi por isso que eu falei
isso Antônio Renato se eu substituir as
luzes da minha casa pela luz vermelha é
possível ler com luz vermelha Não
trapalha mesmo o sono já respondi isso
né Se tiver distância é suficiente não
vai atrapalhar o sono e não for muito
intensa essa luz Por que você nunca fez
vídeo Eu nunca fiz e posso pensar em
fazer né não tem uma uma resposta para
te dar nunca pensei em fazer vídeo sobre
esse assunto se é possível ler com luz
vermelha não tenho certeza eu acho que
vai ser ruim essa leitura você vai ter
dificuldade de ler tá não é para isso
que serve essa luz
não quais são os exames que o hom de 54
anos deve fazer e o que suplementar não
aí tá muito vago essa pergunta Roberto
tava aberto demais isso não vou
responder tá você me desculpa mas
é melhor você entrar no canal e ver lá o
as centenas de vídeos que nós já falamos
sobre esse assunto tá essa pergunta
aberta demais né ficou quase que como
você perguntar qual que é o sentido da
vida o que nós estamos fazendo aqui no
mundo né tá é uma pergunta aberta demais
e outra coisa eu não sei o que que esse
homem de 54 anos tem de deficiência não
vi os exames dele entendeu E e nem deve
mandar aqui tá exame para ser avaliado
Tá bom olha o canal é para isso ser o
canal do YouTube para responder esse
tipo de pergunta muito abrangente tá tem
muito vídeo sobre isso lá no
canal sempre ouvi pessoas falar
inclusive médicos de que depressão não
tem cura só tratamento Qual a sua
opinião Depende se uma depressão eh que
é relacionado a deficiências
nutricionais ou inflamação crônica do
cérebro tem reversão Sim agora tem
depressão que são mais complicadas né
que tá relacionado ao metabolismo
neurotransmissor aí nesses casos eu
concordo que são incuráveis
mesmo uma pessoa tem diabetes Em 200
frequentemente e tem problemas de visão
quais são os riscos e como evitar Como
saber se o açúcar está afetando a
visão você tem que fazer uma avaliação
com o oftalmologista que ele vai tem
vários aparelhos lá no consultório que
ele vai ver se o seu caso aí tem eh
opacificação né
da do cristalino né Se tiver pacificação
do cristalino é que tá tendo eh
problemas de catarata por conta desse
açúcar aumentado no sangue né eles vai
ter catarata é uma condição muito comum
para quem tem diabetes ou pré-diabetes
tá também dá com a idade mas o um dos
principais fatores que acelera a
catarata é o açúcar alto no sangue Ok
então tem que fazer uma avaliação lógica
para ver se o cristalino já está opaco
né se o cristalino tiver opaco é porque
a pessoa já está com catarata e avaliar
a retina também né para ver se a retina
tá tudo bem com a
retina é possível prevenir qualquer tipo
de câncer não não é possível as foras
que você passou no formular do grupo
ainda são eficazes São eficazes Antônio
mas elas não são
eh infalíveis eficaz é uma coisa
infalível é outra né tem cânceres que
não tem como evitar são câncer por
exemplo genéticos é a minoria dos
cânceres mas existe cânceres que são de
origem genética tá que dão em crianças
por exemplo Então não é possível
prevenir todos os cânceres não
infelizmente se uma pessoa toma banho de
sol sentado com a barriga para baixo
cobrindo mas eu já respondi semana
passada
você tá elucubrando demais Antônio eh
tome sol 15 minutos por dia com a maior
parte do corpo exposto tá não fica
preocupado com essa história de barriga
para baixo barriga para cima Costa para
cima Costa para baixo entendeu Já eu já
falei sobre esse assunto a semana
passada eu não sei por você tá repetindo
essa pergunta você Você não assistiu o
vídeo é isso Você tá ao
[Música]
vivo eu acho que não tá ao vivo tá Ah
não você tá ao vivo sim eh você não viu
o vídeo da semana passada ou você não
tava ao vivo na semana
passada tá não não não fica criando eh
eh filigrana demais não eh se expõe ao
sol maior parte do corpo exposto ao sol
15 minutos por dia tá bom não não não
tenta complicar demais a situação que
não precisa
complicar e quanto tempo uma pessoa
absorvendo 20.000 unidades de vitamina D
consegue atingir 80 depende de cada caso
não tem como te responder isso
[Música]
tá se uma pessoa tem problemas
intestinais pode impedir a absorção da
Vitamina D em cápsula pode com certeza
isso pode acontecer não é comum mas pode
acontecer do sol não porque o sol é
através da produção na pele então não
tem nada a ver com intestino né O que tá
produzindo na pele vai ser ativado no
primeiro momento no fígado e no segundo
nor momento no rim
tá açúcar dificulta a absorção de
vitamina D em cápsulas e do sol não Não
dificulta não não tem essa ação o que
reduz a vitamina
D você tá querendo dizer o qu o que
reduz a quantidade de vitamina D no
sangue principalmente a deficiência na
alimentação e na exposição solar
não sei se eu entendi a sua pergunta
Antônio se eu como besteiras biscoito
pães doces muito açúcar mas depois eu eu
por culpa tomo áqua limão misturado com
vinagre de maçã isso pode evitar os
malefícios não não vai evitar vai
Minimizar só tá Não faça
isso evite comer o açúcar tá bom áa
limão não é compensação para
isso o é um bom programa de PC sim eu
tenho aqui instalado no meu notebook
para evitar luz azul sim eu considero um
bom programa Qual é o mais eficiente luz
vermelha ou óculos que protege contra a
luz
azul eu não sei se eu tô entendendo o
computador você pode instalar esse
programa e usar o óculos ao mesmo tempo
eu faria os dois juntos
tá eu acho que quando você coloca qual é
o mais eficiente luz vermelha ou óculos
tá querendo dizer o programa ou óculos
não é
isso ser que eu entendi que você tá
querendo dizer aqui tá usa os dois se
você puder usar os dois melhor ainda
[Música]
tá você tem notado a menos nos casos de
problemas cardíacos sim vasculares e
outras doenças sim depois n nã Sim tenho
notado eu perguntei a você H alguns
meses se os efeitos dos nã eram possível
tratar expelir a substância ainda era
uma informação desconhecida pois ninguém
sabia essas substâncias naturais não
mudou muito não tá não mudou muito quer
dizer não é que é desconhecida continua
sendo uma coisa meio especulativa não
mudou muito não eh se as substâncias
naturais poderiam expedir as substâncias
tóxicas a minha opinião é que você tem
as mesmas informações de um ano atrás eu
não vi nenhum avanço nesse sentido tá tá
bem se você tiverem outras Fontes que
vocês eh ficarem sabendo me falem que eu
vou atrás de dar uma olhada nessas
Fontes Tá mas eu não vi novidades não
até porque a gente não tem exames até
hoje para identificar Protein Spike Eu
acho que vai
ser
É verdade que após premer o limão só
temos 10 minutos para ingerir pós apois
esse tempo não é que o efeito do Limão
some o efeito do Limão ele reduz só não
ele não vai sumir tá ele vai
reduzir a vitamina suplementada pelo a
vitamina D suplementada pelo sol
necessita de
K2 não K2 não tem nada a ver com a
absorção ou produção de vitamina D A K2
é para evitar que o
cálcio que o cálcio absorvido pela
vitamina D vai pro lugar errado tá Se
tiver com intestino inflamado absorção
do Sol é prejudicada não porque isso
depende da pele não do intestino eh e o
método mais eficiente para suplementar
apesar da dificuldade de disciplina de
ficar no sol todos os
dias eu não entendi pera aí pessoal
Tenta colocar a pontuação direitinho
para me facilitar o entendimento
tá Se tiver com intestino inflamado
absorção do Sol é prejudicada respondi
que não ou o sol e o método mais
eficiente para
suplimentar usa a vitamina D junto com
uma gordura saudável omega3 que vai
ajudar na sorção
tá não sei se eu entendi ficou confuso
aqui a a colocação da disciplina tal
tome sol tenta tomar o máximo que você
puder e complementa com a vitamina D
eh de suplemento com gordura saudável
ok Se eu comer dois abacates por dia um
pela manhã outro pelo almoço esses
abacates podem me fazer perder a fome
podem dependendo do se apetite pode né
mas isso é bom paraa maioria das pessoas
isso é bom porque as pessoas geralmente
comem demais e ser substituto para
alimentos não
saudáveis A ideia é justamente que seja
substituto para alimento não saudável né
e me ajudar a entrar em cetose com
certeza o abacate vai te ajudar a entrar
em cetose
tá é possível gerar acetona sem
exercício
físico possível é se você fizer
alimentação bem restrita e jejum você
consegue gerar sim
ã apenas com alimentação Sono
regenerador e água água não tem nada a
ver com cetose tá a água é importante
pro organismo mas não vai aumentar sua
produção de de cetona se você tomar mais
água tá mas é importante pra saúde sono
regenerador também não tem nada a ver
com cetose o que vai fazer diferença na
cetose é exercício físico jejum e dieta
baixa em carboidrato além de é risco
jejum e dieta baixa carboidrato são ess
três
eh qual a minha formação é a minha
formação Ana eu sou formado 27 anos
médico
e depois que eu fiz a o curso de
medicina eu fiquei um ano servindo a
Marinha como médico Depois eu fiz duas
especializações e cirurgia geral e
urologia fiquei quase 15 anos
trabalhando só como urologista normal E
aí tive uma série de problemas na minha
vida vida problemas de saúde pessoal
problema de saúde da minha esposa que
tinha doença autoimune eritema nudoso
depois o meu filho que nasceu com
autismo Então essa série de desafios que
eu tive na minha vida que eu tinha Ena
de repetição tinha testino irritável me
levaram a buscar alternativas E aí eu
encontrei a medicina funcional
integrativa estilo de vida tá e eu fiz
depois vários cursos do lá Ribeiro fiz
formação internacional nos Estados
Unidos da e4m que é o que é a minha
formação
Americana em functional medicine fiz o
curso do Albert Einstein de medicina
integrativa fiz curso do artor Lemos e a
molecular e tenho feito até hoje curso
né o mais recente que eu fiz foi de
kinesiologia médica inclusive que essa
reunião que eu vou ter daqui a pouco é
sobre
isso é uma Faz parte dessa formação
kinesiologia médica tô fazendo
eh quando uma pessoa acorda mesmo que
ela não olhe para o sol o relógio
biológico dela é desperto e assim o
organismo reconhece não precisa olhar
pro sol é só ter contato com a luz solar
tá nem recomendo que você olhe pro sol
que você pode queimar sua sua retina Tá
bom não precisa olhar pro sol não faça
isso que você pode danificar sua
retina sentir sono após o almoço o
principal sintoma de insônia não Não não
é sen sono após o almoço eh tem a ver
obviamente se você dormiu bem ou não na
noite passada mas o principal fator aí é
a quando você come
eh você tem estado pós-prandial a
glicose aumenta no sangue essa glicos
aumentar no sangue isso gera sonolência
e também tem um Outro fator que são a os
constituintes né das paredes das
bactérias que acabam entrando também
pelo intestino e causa uma bacteremia
uma toxemia leve que também dá essa
sonolência Então são os dois motivos
aumento a glicemia e a e aumento do dos
constituintes da da par das bactérias da
corrente sanguina levando uma inflamação
e e a sonolência
sentir sono após o almoço é o principal
sinal de que a pessoa não teve sono
regenerador é um dos sintomas eu não
consider consideraria como principal tá
Ahã eu tenho dificuldade de me lembrar
dos Ossos das pessoas após um bom tempo
sem vê-las já tive diagnóstico de
distimia e transtorno de depressão meu
pai falou que sempre teve dificuldade de
lembrar do rosto das pessoas também
tenho síndrome das pernas inquietas não
consigo me controlar não tenho sonho
regenerador meu pai também tem
dificuldade de dormir minha mãe tem
dificuldade de aprendizagem eu estou
começando a gaguejar dificuldade na fala
tenho 27 anos quais são as suas
orientações a gente uma consulta a dieta
cetogênica Poderia ajudar com certeza
poderia naxa de baixa dosagem poderia te
ajudar mas só em consulta que você pode
ver isso tomar melatonina tomar
elitaurina glicina lisina mungu tem um
monte de coisa que dá para fazer para te
ajudar aí no sono
tá E também melhorando seu
sono pode ajudar na sua
[Música]
memória e aí ter que analisar sem
consultório eu tô te falando de maneira
muito geral aqui
[Música]
tá entender também o seus exam de sai
como é que estão se Quais são os dudos
metabólicos tem que ser corrigidos tá
então é basicamente
isso o que que é lá natural adicionado
aos
chocolates Marilda eu não sei desse
assunto Tá eu vou ficar te devendo não
não estudei esse assunto aí sobre látex
natural adicionados
ao chocolate eu vou dar uma verificada
aqui
rápida ver se eu consigo te responder
isso Dea maneira mínima aqui mas é é um
assunto que eu não tô por dentro tá
aqui a informação que eu tô obtendo
agora é que o látex não é um ingrediente
adicionado a chocolate tá que tá tá
dizendo nessa fonte que é informação
falsa Tá mas eu vou ver isso com mais
calma
depois então porque tem um aviso nas
embalagens É bem parecido com a pergunta
que eu respondi agora a pouco do da
questão aí da soja no sal integral tá no
sal rosa esse aviso pode conter látex
natural se deve a duas razões Porque
existe um sistema de fechamento nas
embalagens que tem
látex e aí poderia aparecer dentro do
produto e poderia ter essa contaminação
cruzada que eu já
comentei e o látex seria um problema
para que pessoas que T alergia ao látex
né Até onde eu sei o látex não é uma
substância tóxica
tá Eh maruda agora se você lê alguma
coisa a respeito depois você me
fala confirma que o HDL maior que 40 é
um valor
ideal entre 40 e 60 não e para homem né
para homem paraa mulher acima de 50 tá e
se for maior de 70 Será disfuncional nem
sempre será disfuncional tá existe um
risco sim do HDL acima de 70 ser
disfuncional mas não é isso não é um
raciocínio automático tem que se avaliar
a função hepática dessa
pessoa HDL disfuncional São pessoas que
TM um distúrbio genético que eh o fígado
dela produz um HDL que é defeituoso tá
por isso que acaba aumentando muito o
valor do HDL porque o corpo tenta
compensar isso de alguma maneira então é
um distúrbio genético que o fígado
produz o HDL que é lipoproteína de alta
densidade que tem eh defeito no
transporte das lipoproteínas
desculpa da dos lipídios não da
lipoproteínas né tem defeito no
transporte dos lipídios então acaba
aumentando muito o valor da HDL é isso
que é um HDL disfuncional um HDL que não
funciona direito imagina que HDL é
uma é um veículo de transporte de
gorduras e de vitaminas lipossolúveis tá
então essa que é a função do das
lipoproteínas então HDL disfuncional ele
não cumpre a função que é devida que é
levar gorduras dos tecidos até o fígado
comer de depois deve ser depois né e
sentir um leve enjoo e uma vontade de
vomitar que pode
ser comer e depois sentir um leve enjoo
é
isso nossa pode ser tanta coisa Antônio
não tem como responder isso agora aqui
não ISO pode ser tanta coisa pode ser
uma série de coisas isso daí pode ser
por exemplo que a pessoa não gosta
daquele alimento e tem uma náusea de
origem psicogênica né Isso é uma grande
causa de gente que não gosta de
determinado alimento e tem náusea e tem
vontade de vomitar uma razão psicológica
Tá mas pode ser tanta doença que causa
isso que fic impossível responder essa
pergunta de uma maneira completa o
adante
alose Seria o mesmo que aulos D
disponível no
Brasil pergunto por se pão mais saudável
disponível segundo alguns especialistas
interessante eu preciso estudar mais
esse assunto tá realmente é um assunto
que eu não estou ainda
[Música]
dominando Sim esse que você viu a lose D
né Eh que é disponível na Loli seri
realista né
eles são o mesmo produto tá então a
lulos d a lulos é o mesmo
produto é um açúcar raro que tem ganhado
destaque como uma alternativa mais
saudável ao açúcar
comum nunca usei esse produto tá então
eu não tenho experiência com ele eu
também nunca indiquei pro
paciente aparentemente tem propriedades
antiinflamatórias e ajuda na prevenção
da obesidade
preciso estudar mais esse
assunto deixa eu até me dê só um
instante
aqui próxima
pergunta Fernando em muitos estudos que
eu vejo a concentração de uma substância
Expressa em esse aqui deve ser micra né
que você colocou u aqui né Deve ser
micra micromoles né e 20 micromoles de
invermectina
Existe uma forma de converter esse tipo
de valor para algo mais prático milg por
kg tem mas ISO vai depender para de
substância para substância porque o
molar e os o molar para você converter
em em em peso né em massa você tem que
saber o peso molecular da molécula tá
não é uma coisa que para igual para
todas as moléculas não cada molécula vai
ter uma conversão diferente de molares
para miligramas por kg
tá
a repulsão monal de testosterona por
meio de gel pode ajudar a diminuir um
shbg mais elevado sim pode mas é mais
comum o efeito vai ser mais intenso com
injeção tá com testosterona injetável
vai ter esse efeito muito mais intenso
de baixar faz mas e veja bem esse hbg às
vezes ele tá lá por algum motivo tá ele
tá ali para te ajudar não para te ferrar
tá então é muito bom investigar bem essa
pessoa antes de sair baixando esse hbg
de qualquer jeito tá porque ele pode
estar lá para compensar um outro
problema dror pratino zumbido se o
paciente não responder o tratamento com
gin cobiloba e vitina apis 4 meses ideal
seria aumentar a dose ou partir para
outra linha aí eu recomendo partir para
outra linha tá inclusive com os
exercícios lá você pode fazer
eh que existe alguns sites alguns canais
no YouTube ensinando a fazer esse
exercício que você dá umas uns toques né
uma percussão numa parte do crânio mas
resumido às vezes é muito difícil de
tratar mesmo
viu recentemente assisti um vídeo que a
pessoa estava em jejum de 24 horas
consumiu 50 g de gulose E verificou
copos cetônicos e glicemia que
permaneceram inalterados após ingestão
medições de 1 em 1 hora durante 3 horas
é possível afirmar baseado nesses
resultados que o jejum foi
mantido
Bom pelo que eu vi aqui da
lose ela tem de 0,2 a 0,4 calorias por
Gama Então ela tem caloria ainda tá bem
mais baixo
um décimo das calorias do açúcar comum
mas tem caloria ainda tá
então essa pessoa em específico não
alterou mas não quer dizer que outras
pessoas não ia alterar Eu acho que isso
vai ser variável de pessoa para pessoa
mas nesse caso específico dessa pessoa
parece que o jejum foi mantido mas eu
acho que isso não vai se manter para
todas as pessoas não porque tem caloria
nesse produto
aí p strong é tão superior a e Protein
ou trata-se mais de
marketing é mais marketing do que
qualquer outra coisa Eliane tá não é um
produto ruim mas é é mais mar do que
realidade tá Se você usar um Protein
Isolado ou hidrolizado vai ser bem
parecido com PEP
strog as pessoas que TM gura no fígado
podem limpar só com silimarina não você
tem que fazer uma dieta específica né a
pele se acostuma com sol não e
consequentemente pode ficar mais tempo
no sol com tempo sim mas aí é uma
compensação mas aí se você vai ficar só
15 minutos no sol não vai dar nem tempo
disso acontecer tá se você tiver pele
clara Tá bom eu não tô recomendando você
ficar no sol tempo suficiente para você
ficar eh moreno tá que aí você tá tendo
uma exposição solar acima do que a gente
tá recomendando tá E aí corre o risco de
você ter uma um câncer de pele deixar o
celular com wi-fi desligado não é o
suficiente para evitar poluição
eletromagnética não você tem que
desligar o
roteador tá e se além de conectar o
wi-fi colocar no modo avião posso dormir
com o celular próximo de 1im 1 m não
porque o celular vai continuar
produzindo radiação eletromagnética
mesmo se você colocar em modo avião tá
Ah eu não recomendo colocar o celular
muito perto de você não vai vai diminuir
Com certeza tá então se você não tem
jeito de você tem que ter o celular do
lado vai vai reduzir a radiação mas não
vai
eliminar a tomada do meu ventilador fica
dentro do meu quarto tem algum problema
tem gente que acredita que tomadas
também podem eh interferir tá isso é um
assunto que eu não cheguei a uma
conclusão
ainda definitiva mas existe muita gente
que acha que até tomada pode ser
prejudicial
eh obrigado pelas três máquinas das
opções Qual é a preferência do Senhor as
três são equivalentes tá Antônio Deixa
eu ver as perguntas ao vivo vou encerrar
já tá tô para encerrar aqui pessoal
ah ó tá tá
tá tratamento com endovenoso com
vitaminas e antioxidantes pode
interferir no tratamento P cirúrgico de
retirar de vi
tiroide e na terapia com iodo não use
antioxidantes se você vaiar fazer o uso
do iodo radioativo tá que vai atrapalhar
a ação do iodo
radioativo que é o objetivo é destruir o
resto do tecido tiroidiano tá se o
objetivo for iodo iodo radioativo não
use agora se for iodo normal pode usar
tranquilamente tá
a pergunta da da luz é se às vezes a
pessoa se Levanta para ir oo
banheiro sim sim mas pode deixar a luz
você não pode acender a luz na hora que
você for o banheiro tá querendo dizer se
vai acender a luz vermelha para ir ao
banheiro né é
isso
entendi Olha eu particularmente eu
prefiro num banheiro no escuro tá mas eu
confio no meu na minha própria percepção
mas você tem medo de se machucar é
coloca a luz vermelha mesmo
tá boa noite Adriana Eloí Denise
Ah isso não não é relevante eliz Eu já
respondi isso
aqui uso de corticoide nasal para
diminuir os sintomas de rinite a longo
prazo pode causar glaucoma Boa pergunta
Fernando existe esse risco sim se a dose
for muito alta e o tempo for muito longo
tá mas se você usar esporadicamente
não a partir de qual percentagem arpag
cosidos aar do diabo é rica em
harpagus tenho que checar isso Eliseu
não tô agora lembrando de cabeça Pera aí
que eu já te
respondo pera aí
por volta de 20% tá 20 a 25% tá
Amend com selo abicab de procedência não
com esse selo Eliseu
eh recomenda-se evitar ingerir a Chanda
quando você tem doença autoimune Quando
a pessoa está com a doença autoimune em
remissão ela pode eu não conheço a
informação que a Chanda não é
recomendada quando Talvez esteja fazendo
um pouco de confusão porque a
Chanda muitas pessoas que tem tem
hipotiroidismo usam a chaga né Eu não
conheço essa contraindicação de usar a
chaga para doença autoimune tá se você
achar a fonte me fale porque eu não
conheço essa informação o sol é o método
mais eficiente para suplementar sim é o
mais eficiente
Antônio quer dizer o mais eficiente mas
tem gente que mesmo tomando sol não vai
atingir os níveis ideais trabalhar
dentro de um prédio com várias redes
wi-fi pode causar câncer isso
inconclusivo ainda eu tem feitas fortes
mas ainda não tá
conclusivo suprimentos hidrossolúveis
com Kefir também são absorvidos como se
fosse
água essa pergunta não tá fazendo muito
sentido
Eliseu quantos litros de
Kefir Kefir não é para tomar que nem
água né o Kefir você vai tomar 500 ml no
máximo 1 litro por
dia esse negócio de látex no chocolate
vi que não tem importância concordo com
você Denise é verdade 100% dos idosos
acima de 90 anos tê câncer de próstata
100% é perto de 100% Por quê a razão
exata não se sabe mas a desconfiança é
por causa do processo de envelhecimento
e senescência celular a o sistema de
defesa fica muito prejudicado E aí ele
escapa as células tumorais que estão
sempre sendo produzidas no organismo né
seja qual for a idade e eu sist tem e
não consegue destruir essas células aí
por isso que aparece esse câncer de
próstata Nessa idade mas são cânceres
indolentes a pessoa não vai morrer disso
não vai morrer de outras
causas sobre a lulos aprendi um pouco
sobre a com a Dra Janaína coen legal
obrigado
Fernando de nada Antônio Renato então
obrigado a vocês terem assistido essa
Live e semana que vem a gente continua E
aí eu vou
apresentar para vocês alguns casos aí
algumas alguns estudos
científicos tá explicando a pergunta
suplementos hidrossolúveis são
absorvidos em
[Música]
água tá se os suplementos forem geridos
com KF também são absorvidos são são
absorvidos sim tá boa noite um abraço a
todos vocês até a semana que vem